e
[Musique]
depuis plus de 400 millions d'années un
verre vie dans le sable les
scientifiques l'ont baptisée l'art et
nicolas marina
franck zal un biologiste français l'a
étudié durant vingt ans avant de faire
son incroyable découverte qui pourrait
sauver des milliers de vies humaines
toute cette aventure a commencé sur une
petite plage de bretagne à saint jean du
doigt qui m'a intéressé c'est est
d'essayer de comprendre en fait
l'adaptation des espèces dans leur
milieu naturel et je me suis intéressé à
un ver marin comment il arrive à
respirer sous l'eau et dans l'air et
puis en fait la respiration saignée en
fait à la circulation sanguine donc je
me suis focalisé sur le sens de cet
animal est en fait si c'est ce vers j'ai
trouvé l'ancêtre de nos globules rouges
c'est une hémoglobine extracellulaire
qui n'a pas le dos au but le rouge qui
n'a pas de type à shanghai et qui permet
à l'arrêt nicole d'arrêter de respirer
quand il est à marée basse et de vivre
sur son stop d'oxygène qu'il a fixés
quand il était sous l'eau donc la
première qualité incroyable de ce ver
marin est de pouvoir stocker son oxygène
pendant plusieurs heures c'est une
molécule qui est capable de délivrer de
l'oxygène donc c'est à transporteurs
d'oxygène et quand vous voyez ici la
marée marée haute marée basse c'est
exactement ce que vous allez trouver en
médecine ce qu'ils appellent ischémie
reperfusion ischémie c'est l'art et
nicole à marée basse reperfusion caylar
et nicolas marées hautes et basses sever
il a répondu parfaitement à ces
problèmes disques emi et d'années me et
donc en fait on a démontré que cette
molécule était capable de délivrer de
l'oxygène dans un tas de pathologies où
on a besoin d'oxygène que ceux sur la
greffe d'organes les maladies
parodontales la cicatrisation la
transfusion sanguine en fait cette
molécule va répondre à énormément de
pathologies dans le domaine médical
le verre peut donc transporter 40 à 50
fois plus de molécules d'oxygène autre
caractéristique
l'hémoglobine est de petite taille soit
250 fois plus petit que les globules
rouges
en cas de blocage par les globules
rouges elle peut facilement se faufiler
pour se rendre directement au greffon le
greffon baigner dans cette hémoglobine
naturelle serait une garantie de non
rejet
les travaux de franck zal vont faire le
tour du monde et surtout fasciné le
monde médical on parle même de
révolution dans le monde de la greffe
d'organes
au centre hospitalier universitaire de
brest de néphrologues yannick le meur a
utilisé la découverte de france gall il
a coordonné dans son service les
premiers essais cliniques de cette
molécule marine
la première utilisation qu on a imaginé
c'est celle de la conservation des
organes vous savez que quand on va faire
une transplantation d'organes il faut
d'abord prélever un greffon d'honneur
ensuite vous allez le conserver dans un
un multiple de conservation le temps que
tout soit prêt pour transplanter chez le
receveur et cette période là entre le
moment où le greffon est prélevé le
moment avec greffer elle et elle est
fondamentale est cruciale pourquoi parce
que justement il ne reçoit plus de sens
donc il ne reçoit plus d'oxygène et donc
cette molécule se transporteurs
d'oxygène tout naturellement on a pensé
la mettre dans le liquide de
conservation pour que tout le temps de
la conservation passivement elle libère
de l'oxygène dans le milieu que donc
l'organe puisse récupérer de l'oxygène
pouvoir limiter les effets délétères de
ce qu'on appelle une hypoxie ce manque
d'oxygène est responsable de lésions au
sein du greffon ce qui va avoir des
conséquences
une fois que l'on va greffer l'organe
la molécule marine va donc permettre de
conserver le greffon plus longtemps et
le maintenir dans un état de
conservation optimale pour les greffes
de rein par exemple c'est un peu moins
important puisque finalement on a on a
une période de temps à peu près de 24
heures gros on sait couple greffer dans
d'assez bonnes conditions mais à des
organes beaucoup plus fragiles coeur le
poumon est effectivement dans ce type
d'organes probablement on pourrait
prendre un petit peu plus de temps met
les équipes un petit peu plus dans de
meilleures conditions pour opérer et
donc effectivement c'est aussi un
deuxième manche
transporter un organe est donc une
véritable course contre la monte chaque
seconde compte là encore les mots
globine marine est incroyablement
efficace car elle permet aux greffons
d'être maintenue plus longtemps en vie
quand on sait que plus de 20% des
greffons meurt c'est un extraordinaire
progrès pour les malades en attente
d'une greffe
quand votre greffon est moins bien
conservé quand vous avez de l'hypoxie il
va se mettre en place des lésions vous
allez pouvoir tout de suite voir leurs
conséquences dès que vous allez greffe
est l'organe pourquoi parce qu'il va
mettre plus de temps à redémarrer et
donc utiliser un transporteurs
d'oxygènes va aider le greffon a
redémarré mais ces lésions initiales
sont aussi responsables en partie de la
durée de vie du greffon c'est à dire de
savoir combien d'années il va
fonctionner la période qui peut durer
plusieurs heures ou il est dans le bocal
là c'est crucial pour nous et c'est
probablement là que se joue une grande
partie de l'avenir de la greffe
[Musique]
quand j'ai trouvé cette molécule je me
suis fait en fait convoquer à paris dans
un club savant qui s'appelait le club du
globule rouge me retrouve avec que des
médecins je commençais à parler en fait
de ma découverte puis les personnes
rayées au démarrage et puis à la famille
monsieur al c'est pas possible vous
n'avez pas trouvé ça nous on cherche à
depuis plus de 40 ans pour en faire à
transporteurs d'oxygènes universel là je
reviens en fait dans mon laboratoire et
je leur dit écoutez c'est bien on a
compris comment ça marche et commence à
respirer et là bas il ya des gens qui
disent comme on peut sauver des vies et
là ils me disent à 90 watts et
scientifique tu reste à ta place de
scientifiques s'il ya quelque chose on
le donnera un industriel et j'ai trouvé
ça tellement frustrant de ne pas pouvoir
aller développer cette molécule jusqu'au
lit du patient que je décide de lancer
dans le développement d'une société
s'appelle et marina respectueux de la
nature franck zal se refusait à piller
le monde animal en allant chercher
sévère sur la plage il a donc créé en
2018 sa propre ferme d'élevage de verre
art et nicole 13 hectares au milieu des
marais salants de noirmoutier en
bretagne
sa capacité de production est estimé
aujourd'hui à 30 tonnes de vers marins
par année c'est le biochimiste alexandre
regard las kelly qui s'occupe de la
production tu as responsable depuis
l'élevage du ver marin qui nous sert de
matière première jusqu'à l'extraction
purification et
la fourniture du produit fini en flacon
au départ c'est des étapes assez
classique de tamisage et toutes ces
étapes c'est des méthodes séparatif qui
vont nous permettre à la fin de
sélectionner uniquement notre molécule d
de la concentrer quand les verts sont
sont matures ils sont congelés tu es
quand on va à décongeler ça dans un
tampon donc c'est à dire un liquide de
salins d'extraction la molécule va
migrer vers ce tampon et puis au fur et
à mesure on va épaissir
concentre à la molécule et à la fin on a
un produit qui est très proche de la
couleur du sang humain
la molécule marine fait aujourd'hui
l'objet d'essais cliniques sur des
humains à grande échelle avec un taux de
réussite assez considérable la première
étape de tous les développements
molécule c'est de montrer que cette
molécule elle n'entraîne pas d'effets
secondaires donc on a fait cette
première étude sur 60 patients qui ont
été greffés avec un rein qui avait été
préservé avec la molécule qu'on appelle
les mots de life et ça a été un succès
puisque on a trouvé que s'est donné
qu'une effectivement était totalement
neutre en avait entraîné aucune réaction
aucun effet secondaire aucun dommage
pour le greffon pour le patient que ça
c'est l'étape fondamentale
avec cette découverte on peut maintenant
imaginer de nombreuses applications
comme la préservation du greffon la
régénération osseuse ou pourquoi pas un
sens universel
aujourd'hui il manque dans le monde 100
millions de litre de sang tous les ans
pour satisfaire les besoins de la
population mondiale
tout le pan des pathologies où vous
pouvez imaginer qu'il ya le mot ischémie
c'est à dire qu'il ya un manque
d'oxygène est touché par cette molécule
après la problématique sera d'être
capable d'administrer le produit jusqu'à
l'an l'organe la lésion ou l'endroit où
on veut on veut agir que ce soit le
coeur que ce soit le cerveau et pourrait
même être un substitut sanguin c'est à
dire remplacer
les transfusions sanguines
on a été contactés au démarrage de la
voiture des marinas parle us navy ils
ont vu en fait que la technologie était
extrêmement intéressante et leurs
problématiques ce n'était pas forcément
le choc hémorragique du militaire sur un
champ de bataille c'étaient les
explosions
une bombe qui a explosé à quelques
dizaines de mètres d'ici va avoir un
effet de souffle extrêmement important
sur votre boîte crânienne et créa une
hémorragie si on ne l'enlève pas cette
7ème en fait cérébrale votre cerveau va
mourir et il voulait en fait avoir à peu
près une heure de possibilité d'utiliser
cette technologie pour un des militaires
à l'arrière et c'est à une heure qu'on a
fait ces deux heures et demie avec des
très faible quantité de ce produit là et
l'autre intérêt c'est que comme c'est
une molécule d'hémoglobine
extracellulaire on peut l'avoir en
poudre donc vous pouvez la lyophilisés
vous pouvez avoir 5 ans de date de
péremption à température ambiante senti
page sanguin alors que quand vous vous
donnez votre sang ces 42 jours à 4
degrés avec un type à chang donc vous
révolutionner complètement en fait la
possibilité d'utiliser
ces molécules au mois de septembre
dernier on a réalisé en inde une
première mondiale avec la molécule de la
société et marina on a réussi à
reconstituer les deux avant bras du
patient qui avait été sectionnée lors
d'un accident durant les nombreuses
heures qu'a duré l'opération les deux
avant-bras ont baigné dans un liquide
qui compte est la molécule avec son
incroyable apport d'oxygène la molécule
marine a donc permis aux greffons de ne
pas subir de lésion et de redémarrer
plus rapidement
franck est ce que tu as un petit peu des
retours de cette intervention en inde
cette première mondiale enfin ils disent
que le patient commence à récupérer de
plus en plus en fait la mobilité de ses
doigts c'est marrant c'est que tu as
deux mouvements de doigts quand il perd
fusent en fait le produit et c'est dire
combien de temps la cette intervention
14 heures en fait elle a durant 14
heures avec plus de 50 personnes
comme on dit dans le milieu scientifique
une pellicule de rupture c'est qu'il y
aura un avant et un après n'est pas
encore mais il ya des potentialités
énormes pour cette molécule de par le
mécanisme d'action qui est à la fois
très simple apporter de l'oxygène et les
fondamentale puisque finalement on peut
pas vivre sans oxygène donc il ya
vraiment des potentialités énormes pour
cette molécule dans l'évolution nous
avons reçu
pour moi la nature c'est une
bibliothèque d'innovation et l'homme a
tendance à brûler les livres de
l'innovation c'est ce qu'on appelle la
biodiversité on va brûler en fait les
espèces inverse ce qu'un verre donc on
peut le détruire non le vert il est
extrêmement important sur dans
l'environnement donc pour moi en fait il
faut plutôt lire les livres plutôt que
de les brûler et ça c'est vraiment tout
le message que j'essaie de faire passer
et dire que ce ver se cachait dans le
sable depuis des millions d'années il
remonte aujourd'hui à la surface pour
donner la bouffée d'oxygène qui sauvera
des millions de vies humaines
[Musique]